The joe rogan experience.
You know what's crazy like?
I always say to you like,
oh,
I don't mean to pronounce his
name wrong and let them go. Right?
Like when he fought steel picking
Dano Ugad on when he fought my mat.
Immigrant mentality. Like
a motherfucker. Yeah,
he hits hard and all that stuff like that,
but now that dude's still
going to be more dangerous.
Now he's gonna fucking take that loss
and come back down man fucking machines.
You gotta think how crazy it is that he
went from being a guy who was homeless
too five years later fighting
for the heavyweight title.
This is like a total amount of training,
five years of elementary training,
fighting for the heavyweight title,
and he's the favorite.
He's the favorite over guys.
He defended it twice. I mean,
it's crazy. That's how talented
he is. That's how terrifying is.
That's how special he is.
But Oh,
a loss like that to a guide like that
to a real champ like Steve Bay at that,
once you realize where the top
of the game is, there's another,
there's a few more things to learn.
There's a lot more days to get in and
training, but that guy has just begun.
He's just began five years ago.
He didn't know shit.
He's way better now than he was two
fights ago. Yeah, I see the difference.
I see the difference in the way he moves.
When he fought Overeem,
it was since significantly different than
when I saw him in his first and second
fights as first second fights.
He was very good but just insanely strong.
He would hit guys with these combinations
and clean technique to man. He's like,
he's not just a physically strong guy.
He's also very smart because he's
learning to do everything mechanically.
Very good.
It's not like a guy who's only been
striking for like three or four years,
so they look a little tight and weird,
but they can if they land,
they got a lot of power. Nah Man,
everything is clean. Like you said,
some Gig of those trenches, Jack. Oh
Dude. That type of work gets you a tough,
he's tough. He's just a special
athlete and if he keeps going, man,
I mean sh boy,
that guy.
Learning more to think about how
little you learn in five years.
Most of these guys have way more
time in way more time in wrestling,
way more time in kickboxing. The
average guy, by time it gets to the UFC,
I would like to know what the number
is like how many years of training and
competing they have, but it's
gotta be more than two like he was.
He was like right in the
UFC and smashing people.
It's his amazing story, man. It's an
amazing story and for a lot of people,
the way it ended is a good lesson for
martial artists. It's a good lesson.
See what, even if you weren't in Gyn,
who fan, you're bummed out that he lost.
I appreciate that. I'm going
and gone. Who Fan the fan too,
but I'm more of a fan of
mixed martial arts. I, I'm a,
I'm a fan of an honest,
like extreme,
like I wanna I want to know what it
is. Like what, what is this like?
What's this? What's this
contest right here? What's,
what's actually going on here?
What's going on here is
phenomenal athletic talent,
massive potential.
Like Super Alpha athlete versus one of
the toughest guys ever who's been in the
game longer. Who knows more. He's
wrestled. He's been fighting way more.
He's been in the trenches way more times.
He said dig deep.
He knows what it's like to be really
hurt and tired in a fight. She,
I appreciate the strategy of like how
do you go into fight a guy like perfect.
It was like rocky against Mr T.
Yeah, that's what exactly was like.
So it was like heart and
fucking a little smart.
Stay away from that punch. It had to be
and I, I haven't watched the full fight,
you know I was working then man.
I don't want them fucking stage.
My brother getting hit by France.
It's in Ghana. We put MMA gloves,
worst thing that can happen to a person.
He's terrifying and Steve Bay got
cracked multiple times in that fight.
It sounds like you didn't get hit. He
got cracked, but he had made up his mind.
He was going nowhere. He knew what to
do. He'd been there before. That's an,
that's an incredible lesson,
which just for the overall, the,
the sport for the,
for mixed martial arts in general and
the lesson is like he figured out like he
had like the craziest end of
video game character ever. Right?
And God was like the big, like the big
boss in a video game that like, fuck,
I got to fly.
I got to play against this guy that's
in Gado and steep a figured out how to
beat him being 20 plus pounds
lighter than him, you know, way,
way less intimidating in terms of his
physical presence. All those steep based,
pretty fucking intimidating,
but in Ghana was so intimidating.
He's so next level two 65
natural giant crazy frame.
You look at it when you're
next to steep batch,
when you realize how big
is too big fell on TV.
You don't look that big when you're next
to him. Be like, this guy's a big fuck.
He's a big fuck you. You're walking around
his asset is his mind though, James?
Yes. Yes. Come on. Yeah, I've been
talking to him. I get mentality. Fucking,
you talked about the Wikipedia page dog.
I told you immigrant mentality
with media page. Listen,
American ingenuity is fucking brilliant.
And with the immigrant mentality mix,
like let's say you're still am American,
but it that could have called you Steve,
but he could still call them steep and
Mayo chick to remember where the fuck do
you came from. You understand me? His
father came. That's really a weird,
okay.